just look at the devastation around me
look at that that car
has been thrown because of the power of
the floods that gushed through here
down the street into a lamppost imagine
the ferocity of that
and explains everything else that you're
seeing a town
that is covered in thick clinging
mud you can smell it as you walk around
and in front of a
so many we've walked past hundreds of
houses here now all of their possessions
out on the street covered in mud
unusable so many white goods furniture
cars the whole town has been
effectively wrecked now today we are
seeing people coming back
into our viola i think it's a
combination of of volunteers people who
wanted to come here
and help it's officials it's army
uh and other services emergency services
and it's also residents seeing people
coming back to their homes often wearing
the clothes that they were wearing
when they left a couple of days ago and
being
greeted by this sort of scene by
cars that are covered in mud or wrecked
by
look at this this is a pile of
possessions it looks
like dump from a distance it looks like
mud but if you get closer
you can see bottles of wine tables
lamps doors white goods
this is actually a portrait of
life of normal day-to-day life
in a pretty normal town like this and
this tells you how in a matter
of a few hours this town
was ripped apart so the cost of
putting this all back together in this
town that might be
350 million euros but for germany
it's going to run into billions surely